[Music]
at OIG have you tried turning it off and
on again after Chris O'Dowd scored his
first big role playing Roy in the
British sitcom The IT Crowd audiences in
the u.s. known from his hip movie
bridesmaids he's also been featured and
mrs. forty and Molly's game you can see
him now in the new season of the popular
series get shorty the show is inspired
by the best-selling novel of the same
name Oh dad plays a hit man trying to
launch a movie career and reconnect with
his daughter nicknamed shorty and when I
asked what's going on with you
you won't talk about it you pulled out
of my movie Emma and now it's coming out
and I'm betting you don't want to hear
me banging on about it all day do you
think I made a mistake
no no that's not what I'm saying okay
dad I am happy to hear about it but I'm
not asking about the movie what happened
to the guy that shot you I never I never
said I was shot do you still work for
those people chardee you want to know
what's going on with me the Admirals
mistress that's it that's it if that's
not what you want to talk about that I'm
sorry and Chris O'Dowd joins us once
again here at the table welcome back
thanks so much for having me yes
so look I told you this the last time I
love the i.t that I mean that was a
great series but this is really
interesting because you're a hit man and
you're struggling to be a movie producer
and to be a good dad you're really
successful at being a hit man yes
struggling a bit with you the fatherhood
is more of a struggle yeah you're not
the only one no me included it's tricky
but yes I have a daughter who's about to
reach teenagehood and going through all
the absurdities that that brings played
wonderfully by Karen and Todd I'm
breaking up with my wife in at the start
of season two it kind of turns into
something of a Kramer vs Kramer
situation where the get shorty is
something of a custody battle get shorty
and then trying to battle with
making a movie that he likes and it's
got a kind of a lot of work versus
Commerce talking points some very sexy
sell here work versus Congress Chris
Chris big you're playing we know you as
the charming affable good guy like love
interest and here
pardon my phrasing but you're kind of a
violent jerk in this in this series is
the beginning of the season especially
it's like truer to life we see the real
know I've been faking the charm for all
them years
oh no it's kind of nice and to key into
all of those different parts of yourself
and he is a little violent but he's
somewhat put upon he is coming out of a
very difficult situation of this kind of
crime family led by this very powerful
glamorous but psychopathic kind of
matriarch and trying to find a way of
love for his family to go on to keep
them safe and he thinks that going to LA
and making a movie will lead to that so
it's it's a lot of challenges and you
describe this season as a darker one how
do things for your character miles get
out of control well he ends up at the
end of season one with a film that's not
very good it's actually more annoying
than being bad it's decidedly mediocre
and he has to try and transform that
through editing into something that's
palatable for the public so he ends up
in the editing room taking a lot of
adderall ends up going off the ropes
drinking a bit too much crash in his car
ending up in a motel and having a
relationship with a woman who's into
crystal therapy so true-to-life
average weekend in Montauk so listen
you've got this new film coming out with
Ethan Hawke and Rose Byrne it's called
Juliet naked yes
tell us about it sounds right i mean
they're they're incredible actors yeah
it's very good it's a nick hornby book
and it's it's kind of about obsession
I suppose I'm obsessed with Ethan
Hawke's character who is ex
kind of singer/songwriter from the 80s
and 90s something of a Jeff Buckley type
of figure Sam yeah he's a recluse now
and I'm I'm with Rose Byrne in it and I
try and track him down and it doesn't
end well for me when we track him down
and bring on you play like a big fan of
this like singer that's right I'm a
fanatic yeah he ends up in my house and
goes to my basement which is just very
creepy very creepy yes and she has never
seen necessarily the attraction to his
music but in person finds them much more
attractive we love I speak for us
collectively we love Rose Byrne oh she's
an Aussie yes she is you are not from
the continental United States
this is a fact when you audition for
bridesmaid rumor has it that you never
thought you were gonna get the role
that's right and now here you are a
superstar on American stage and screen
about stage but screen for sure are you
surprised that it's gone so well not
really of course I am but I the truth is
I never had very high expectations for
myself so all of this is wonderful but
even if it hadn't been I don't know if
it would have mattered so much
expectations lore and the gratitude hi
you'll always be surprised yes go back
to that bunny suit anytime - sounds like
a weird joke if your standards low and
your dreams big thank you my friend the
new season of get shorty airs Sundays on
epochs and a reminder you can hear more
CBS this morning on our podcast
available on Apple's podcast app or
wherever you like to download your
podcast